foreign
have you ever seen
somebody else's child behave appallingly
in a supermarket
did you secretly blame the mum for her
lack of control
or did you even feel a little bit smug
because you knew that that your child
would never behave like that
to 10 long years I was that Mum you were
staring at
and those stairs hurt
they made me feel I was failing as a
parent and it wasn't just
other people who I didn't know in shops
that were that were judging me that
judgment came from friends from Family
from Healthcare professionals from
School staff and from social workers
being judged consistently for such a
long period of time
diminished my self-esteem and my
self-confidence
it left me feeling crushed and broken it
had a really overwhelming impact on my
ability to be able to do anything well
including my ability to be the best
parent possible to my three children at
exactly the time they really needed me
to be right at the top of my game
now my middle child Toby
he's gorgeous
he is funny he's boisterous he loves
people
but he also has a profound intellectual
disability he's autistic and he can't
talk
and that means that sadly Toby's also
had to get used to being judged and
stared at as well just think what a
scary place the world must be for Toby
and he can't even ask any questions to
try and help him make sense of what's
going on around him when somebody can't
talk often the only effective way they
have of communicating is through their
behavior
and
throughout Toby's childhood the more
frightened he became the more
frightening his behavior became as well
for those 10 years our family lived with
terrifying violent and challenging
Behavior with somebody getting hurt
nearly every single day now Toby had a
fantastic team of specialists around him
but nobody knew how to help
staff had not had any training in
anxiety-led challenging behavior and
there were so few if any services that
had been developed to support families
like ours and here we are nearly 20
years later and nothing's changed
instead of getting the essential help
and
urgent support these families need
they are instead being
repeatedly
and wrongfully blame shamed and judged
for their children's anxiety-led
behavior and they're also being told
that they're being too soft and that
they're spoiling their child throughout
all those times everyone was urging me
to parent Toby harder and stricter and
more firmly I followed their advice to
the letter but Toby's Behavior got worse
not better of course it did I could see
that now he was a frightened and
distressed little boy he needed love and
kindness
being harsh and straight was never going
to work but I didn't know that then
so I really tried to follow all that
advice
everyone was singing for the same song
sheet and the message was loud and clear
that I was an incompetent parent who was
fading my child and badly let him down
his brother and sister those years were
incredibly tough and all that judgment
made it so much harder a little bit of
kindness and an attempt to understanding
could have gone so far
over time in the absence of any
professional help I eventually develop
my own wild and wacky strategies that
sometimes worked however people then
were often as bewildered by my own
decidedly odd behavior as they were by
Toby's particularly at hospital
appointments now hospitals are very
controlled and structured environment
staffed by highly trained professionals
that's absolutely everything that Toby
is not
Toby's noisy and he's playful and he's
chaotic and he's disruptive
it was always going to be a disconnect
the other thing about Toby is he's
incredibly Hospital savvy
he can spot a hospital a healthcare
professional at a hundred paces and
you're not always his favorite people
he also knows things about hospitals
that you don't know he knows that if
he's halfway down a really long Hospital
Corridor if he shouts at the top of his
voice it's going to create magnificent
echoes
and people are going to react
almost every time within seconds of
arriving at a hospital people were
giving us a wide birth and they were
already rolling their eyes now keeping
Toby safe and what unhappy in a hospital
isn't easy but if I failed people could
get hurt and Equipment broken so the
stakes were high I was constantly on
hyper alert ready to LEAP in to distract
or divert
if things looked a bit tricky and it was
essential that I was able to communicate
with Toby in ways that I knew he'd have
the best chance of understanding
unfortunately there wasn't always time
to explain to people what I was doing
and why so if you wanted to take Toby's
blood or to do his blood pressure I
might thrust my arm out like this and
ask you to pretend to do it to me first
because that way Toby has a better
chance of understanding what's going on
so he's going to be more likely to
cooperate
Toby also understands things much better
if they're sung to him
so if you need to listen to his chest
and healy's to lift his T-shirt up to
let you be able to do it I might have to
tell him like this
where is Toby's tummy where is Toby's
tummy where is Toby's tummy show it to
the doctor
laughs
[Applause]
thank you
Toby isn't naturally compliant but he
loves playing games so at the end of an
appointment if Toby is far too happy
sitting on your floor and emptying all
your cupboards to want to stand up and
leave I might have to play where is
Toby's face
I play this by cupping my hands like
this in face shape and putting it all
over the room saying things like
is that Toby's face where is Toby's face
has anybody seen Toby's face oh could
that be Toby's face
eventually he'll cotton onto what I'm
doing her burst out laughing he'll stand
up he'll lean his hands into my face
and great except that if it's a really
bad day we may still have to perform the
entire array dance before we can leave
you in peace now
by now the look of the face of the
average clinician is one of sheer horror
and fear
and there's a clear assumption that I've
lost the plot and gone bonkers
the very worst thing that can happen
next is if that clinician decides to try
to take over
and because they obviously can't believe
I know what I'm doing
that has meant that sometimes Toby's
been physically manhandled out of Rome
while he and I are both being told of
really loudly
that's almost exactly what's guaranteed
to frighten Toby into the worst type of
behavior possible
sometimes we've had a fantastic
experience we've met some great people
who've been really happy to join in and
play along it's remarkable how well a
game of hide and seek can lend itself to
assessments of cognition
communication skills mobility and even
Toby's breathing
but whenever I've really felt judged in
those situations all I've wanted to do
is to run away as fast and as far as I
can as of your office
now when I'm feeling like that it's
almost impossible for me to open up and
share with you my real concerns about
Toby's health
which means that's going to make your
job much harder in being able to assess
him and to come up with treatment
options which of course is going to
impact on Toby
and his long-term outcomes and
well-being
being judgmental really can be the
starting place of Health inequalities
but being judgmental is so easy when you
judge people who already feel vulnerable
You're only ever going to make us feel
more ashamed more rejected and more
unworthy
kindness is so important it can make
such a big difference kindness is
powerful and it really can
bring out the best in all of us but I've
got another favorite word curiosity when
we stay curious
we keep asking those why questions which
helps us to build Bridges towards better
understanding
when we stay curious it keeps our hearts
and our minds open which helps to
prevent us forming those judgments
if ever you see me with Toby and my
behavior is looking a bit off the very
best question you can possibly ask me is
do you need any help and if so what can
I do
eventually we were referred to a
fantastic team who totally understood
why young people like Toby can develop
these
anxiety-led behaviors Dr Helen Simmons
and David Smith they were there for us
they listened they just understood they
just got it and never once did they make
me feel ashamed blamed or judged I was
so excited that first day that David was
due to come to our house and I couldn't
wait to ask if that all-important
question so David how are we going to
change Toby's Behavior
David put his cup of tea down he looked
at me
he took in a deep breath and then he
dropped a bombshell
nowathon I'm not here to change Toby's
behavior I'm here to change yours what
I was not happy I was horrified it
sounded like the same old same old blame
judgment all over again but it wasn't
what he was showing me is that I had to
change first
so
I had to unlearn almost everything I
thought I knew about parenting
what I learned was about anxiety and
exactly why
Toby's Behavior became so difficult
because he anxiety made him so terrified
I learned that when he was lashing out
what he was really trying to do was to
scream out for help because he felt so
frightened and the world was so
confusing
and he needed help
I learned that when he had hurt me it
wasn't because he hated me it was
because he trusted me more than anybody
else in the world
to be able to offer him that help that
he so badly needed
so
up until then
I had gone up and up and up in terms of
being stricter and harsher and firmer in
the way I parented Toby just like
everybody had told me to I thought I'd
tried everything I didn't think there
was anything left
Helen and David showed me that there was
an entirely different direction
and I could go down and down and down as
well
so my parenting became more loving more
understanding
more collaborative and Kinder it changed
everything
Toby responded brilliantly and it was
like watching magic happen Toby's now 28
he's incredibly happy he's doing so well
and things are really good I now know
that it was never about Toby's Behavior
it was always about trying to find ways
for to help Toby feel
safer and less frightened in a world
that offered seemed confusing to him
I now run bold hope it's a parent-led
organization devoted to teaching parents
and professionals
how to move children with anxiety-led
behavior towards happier times
so far through our work we know of over
2 000 children who've successfully
achieved this we know from research that
our prison population
is significantly over-represented by
adults who have ADHD or who have a
learning disability or who are autistic
but it doesn't have to be like this
for decades we've been giving parents
the wrong advice
and then we've been blaming them when it
goes even more on
If instead we can step in early enough
and provide parents with
the strategies the supports the skills
and the confidence they need they really
can change the course of their child's
life but this is not a parental
competence issue far from it
this group of parents have taught me so
much and shown me how much can be
achieved with tenacity true courage
hope and unconditional love
these parents their parenting skills are
already at Ninja level
and they've helped me to realize that
all that time long ago so were mine if
you see something that doesn't quite
make sense there may still be a clear
logic as to what they're doing and why
they're doing it
please don't judge
please stay curious
and please keep asking those why
questions
because that's how you can help somebody
like me
feel valued
understood and included
and let's be honest doesn't that what
the NHS is all about
thank you
[Applause]